tell you another thing i can't handle  anymore stephen a smith  after he posted that video of him  sparring it's like i'm going to listen  to you talk about an athletic endeavor  i know  and and the confidence with which  he speaks about sports  and i just now i look at everybody at  espn  i'm just like are these all guys just a  bunch of uncoordinated guys in [ __ ]  suits now why would he want it out there  i think he thought it looked good  well yeah he did but dude i mean  somebody should  wait listen with all the friends he has  in sports somebody should have called  and been like dude that's not the way  you throw a right hook  i can't watch him anymore anytime i see  him i just see him picture him like  i was watching him i'm going this guy is  talking to charles barkley  breaking down a series charles barkley  one of the greatest nba players of all  time is talking to a guy  this [ __ ]